you
hi everyone is cherry this is video too
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and we're going to have a
brief look at the relative value of the
chess pieces or in other words a basic
point system that we could be using to
help guide our play to help us know
what's a good exchange bad exchange or
even exchange of pieces for example for
playing is white here and start out like
so and I'm in no way saying that this is
a good start to a chess game my main
point of emphasis is to simply show a
particular exchange of pieces is it a
good idea to allow this exchange to
allow our rook to be captured and get
the bishop in return the answer to that
is no because the rook is more valuable
than the bishop now how much more
valuable well let's have a look at this
basic point system that I'm referring to
it runs as follows the pawn is worth 1
the knight is worth 3 the bishop is
worth 3 the rook is worth 5 the Queen is
worth 9 and the King is priceless
now so far with all this talk about
points it's easy to maybe be misled in
thinking that well the more points I get
I'm going to win No
the objective of the game is to give
checkmate don't lose sight of that
sometimes there are plenty of positions
where you could have fewer points on
board less material in other words those
two terms they are points and material
are often used interchangeably you can
have more points and still lose the
objective is to give checkmate this will
simply act this point system here will
simply act as a helpful guide to us okay
now if I'm to give just a little bit of
insight about a few of these values for
to first look at just the Queen
what is it maybe about the Queen that
gives her such a high worth here
assigning a value of 9 well one thing we
could say about her as we saw in the
first video
the queen and king alone is enough to
give checkmate she's all she has the
attributes of both rook and Bishop okay
a more interesting question or a more if
we look at the rook and Bishop comparing
those two pieces is a little bit more
interesting what is it about the rook
that makes it more valuable than the
bishop well on that we can say well the
bishop maintains its color and so in
some sense the bishop is deficient right
if it's starting out on a light square
it must remain on a light square for the
rest of the game it's only moved to
light squares control light squares the
rook doesn't have that problem it can
make use of the whole chessboard
when we compare rook and Knight the rook
is a long-range piece it can go from one
side of the board to the other in just
one move then I can't do that okay now
let me reiterate something here this is
a basic point system that we can use
that will help us make good decisions
okay to know who if any benefits from a
particular exchange of pieces using this
guideline using this basic point system
is a for now at least a fine starting
point but do know that as we develop a
deeper understanding of the game will
also be refining our way of thinking
about the game okay and the value of the
pieces as we develop a better
understanding of the game it's going to
become more apparent to us that the
bishop tends to be worth a little bit
more than the knight and without going
into any great detail for now and to
give just one quick reason for this
let's just say that it's really nice
it's very often the case it's really
nice to have a long-range piece it's
really nice to be able to go from one
side of the board to the other and just
one move
having that attribute
in a piece is quite useful okay the
night does not have that capability
takes in several moves okay now I'd like
to just play through a game here to show
you how it may how some game might play
out where you have a lot of even
exchanges in fact this game I'm showing
right now that's all we get to see is
just one even exchange after another
black just captured upon and a couple
moves later white is getting it back we
get to see all even exchanges in this
one night for night and I'm going
through this game for a few reasons
one is to just show how a game might
play out just some even exchanges here
and also to draw your attention to some
basic chests vocabulary one detail here
is that when I'm using the word pawns
sound this is going to sound weird but
when I say the word pawns I'm referring
to pawns when I say the word pieces I'm
referring to anything but pawns okay
also I'd like to tell you a little bit
about knights and bishops term that we
can use to describe knights and bishops
is minor pieces whereas the rooks and
the Queen's we consider them major
pieces in this game all pieces all minor
pieces and all major pieces get
exchanged Bishop for Bishop and
eventually we have the other bishops
being exchanged back-to-back exchanges
three points for three just there and
this is where we now have a little bit
of a combination to finish up here and
this next move we have Queen takes rook
at first it appears we're giving up nine
we only got five Queen four rook
exchange that doesn't seem so good for
white at first glance and now with this
next move we're giving up five we're
getting three and our opponent's getting
five so that seems like it's another bad
trade but we'll soon find out how sneaky
or how tricky
tonight could be in the game at the end
of the day he's going to get nine points
and then black gets three at the end of
it all at the end of that combination
everything is balanced this is a game of
all even exchanges I'd like to also
point out that does not imply this does
not imply that when you make even
exchanges in chess it's just going to
end up as a tie that is not the case at
all
it happened in this game but it will
certainly not happen in all games that's
for sure this game by the way if you're
curious was from the 2013 World Chess
Championship match between Magnus
Carlsen playing his white and Vishy
Anand and it was at this point they
agreed to a draw there's not a way to
make progress but just to emphasize the
importance of material in chess I showed
earlier about giving up your rook and
only getting a bishop in return that
wasn't a good choice and you can expect
that if you're doing something like this
if this game was to continue if black is
making move like so being down just one
pawn that's a big deal don't just treat
pawns as if all they're not so
significant they're significant okay
you're going to lose upon that pawn is
going to turn into a queen and we know
from our first video how powerful of
course a queen can be okay my main point
of emphasis in this video just as a
close was to draw your attention to a
basic point system okay this will be
helpful to us this is just one factor
the factor of material points in chess
there are plenty of others but for now I
just wanted to focus on material this
basic point system of 1 3 3 5 & 9 and
this is going to be a helpful guide to
you when you play the game ok so that's
all for this video as always I hope you
got something out of it and I will catch
you in video 3 take care bye
you